hey chess friends national master james
kenton iii here with chess.com and today
we have game of the day with the white
pieces we have stock fish new and with
the black pieces we have leela chess
zero crazy game let's get right into it
here it is so stockfish new hits is with
e4 and e5 in response now are you ready
for this one what do you think they
played knight f3 knight c3 bishop c4
b3
d4
well we're going back to the land back
into the day of time going back in time
f4 kings gambit wow f4 king's gambit
from stock fish new gonna get very
exciting e takes f4 knight f3 mainline
stuff and then h5 which is a a rare one
in a way you usually see like g5 or
bishop c5s or even you know knight f6
knight c6 d5 like there's all these
other moves h5 is not one played a whole
lot but it is played h5 and then d4 d4
attacking f4 here going for just king's
gaming fashion and g5 to follow there it
is right behind him now you do see a lot
of the g5 with h5 not as much but it
definitely is played and after the g5
line there's h4 h4 immediately hitting
of course the g5 pawn and after g4 what
do you do about this knight right well
you got to move into g5 this is the best
place and of course if you go g1 it
doesn't make sense knight d2 blocks
everything so he goes to g5 but you're
asking yourself wait the night's trapped
the night is trapped i literally have no
moves for the night that i can go to
that i won't be captured on
so
stockfish news says okay yeah we were
doing this anyway bishop takes that
board in fact believe it or not as we
lose this piece quotation marks it's
equal after f takes g5 bishop takes g5
and bishop e7 you are down a piece
so you need to be very very careful here
with the white pieces queen to d2
because we want to defend this because
this was actually attacked and after
taking twice he will go up a pawn or
actually even more material in a way
queen to d2 defending
d6 i need to develop my pieces white has
a huge center open game open rook file
things like that let's see what happens
knight to c3 defending the e4 pawn which
is not even attacked yet but also the
fact that you have to develop your
pieces maybe even castling queen side
bishop to e6 developing a piece and then
we see bishop to d3 developing a piece
you also can castle now king side with
the of the open rook file bishop takes
g5 and h takes g5 here still in equal
position h4 was actually a very top
engine move and also queen to e7 knight
d7 really didn't show up in the radar
but that was what was played from leela
zero here knight to d7 maybe preparing
to castle castle queenside and also
develop the rest of the pieces after
knight to d7 white castles we get out of
the way we open the rook file open like
this hoping that he doesn't move his
queen of course this is little zero so
come on now but queen is seven so now we
can castle queen side now in
anticipation of this find a move
that would stop or even influence what
happens when black castles queenside so
this is exactly what stockfish new did
they made a move here that yeah you can
still castle but you're gonna run into
some trouble and in fact it's a very
strong move here let's see if you can
find it
here it is in fact it is not g6 which
looks like a move with rook f7
intentions but the bishops there maybe
you want to push here maybe try to trap
the bishop in something like that the
move is actually knight to b5 very
strong move attacking c7
right and if you castle maybe knight
takes asap so he castles hey go ahead
take on a7 but that was not the
intention at all in fact the intention
here was queen to c3 that's for me now
you have d5 and we live looking great
here hitting uh the x-ray of the brook
and you're hitting mate at the same time
okay black plays c6 hey we're not having
that you're not it's not going to be a
cakewalk like that here and of course
you could play d5 here
but knight takes a7
a7 was that was the better move knight
takes a seven and now after king to b8
well what do you do here now now you're
down a piece technically we did sack one
piece the knight on g5 what do you do
now here
your knight on a7 is hanging you think
d5 right
pawn d5 that's what we saw hey my
knight's trapped maybe i could try to
defend him but i don't know if i'm
really going to do that i don't know if
this is really going to work defending
this knight so maybe i should play d5
you agree there sounds pretty good d5
right hitting the bishop right we go
here sounds like a move it looks great
doesn't it now of course d5 is actually
not the best move at all because of
knight e5 and it's like oh wow and then
d takes e6 right or you take this and
then i can even take and now whoa i'm up
a piece
remember you sacked a piece this knight
here
you sacked it earlier and now i'm back
up a piece again
after you've got it back temporarily
looks like it works
but not really
in fact
stockfish new said well i'm down one
piece why not give another one knight
takes c6 takes and takes and after uh
takes there was queen to b4 check right
you could also take here too as well but
queen before check was more direct so
there's two pieces sacrifice on two
opposite sides of the board and this
game is still going on queen before now
believe it or not the engine is like
yeah it's equal equal you know it's
equal
wow the two pieces down and the king
side attack here and the pieces are
still trying to develop as black or
black here so after knight takes c6 b
takes c6 c c6 and queen to b4 check
okay king c8 runs into mate immediately
bishop a6
king c7 queen b7 me
no good right no good at all okay king
a8 actually runs into queen a5 anyway so
of course uh um lelacha zero just went
for king a7 and then we have the a5
check king to b8 and then what would you
do in this position so this is going to
definitely help your attacking skills
what would you do in this position give
you a few seconds to figure this one out
what are you going to choose
here it is right here the move actually
was bishop a6 if you found bishop a6
very good very nice move getting another
piece into the attack so now this is
actually check and checkmate check
checkmate so you have to stop it so
after k7 now of course this move looks
very appealing right but you can
actually just take
and after pawn takes you have queen b5
check easy you also have rook f to e1
right but queen b5 check is very good
easy and then after bishop takes d5 you
can play rook a to e1
which is really nice and c4 in some
cases but there's like a perpetual i
think in there so you have to be careful
still but rook after e1 is a little bit
different
and also queen takes g5 is coming so
lots of play lots of play but after
bishop a6 there was king 2a7 actually
king a7
stepping right into the x-ray that's
very hard to do very scary but of course
this is a scary position for black
anyway after king 2a7 now what would you
play in this position here guys
why it's a move there's many moves in
fact that you can make discovery wise
what would you do though and then we'll
see what stockfish new did
after the king a7 move
you can in fact play bishop d3 which is
strange
very strange actually
this is the engine recommendation bishop
d3 very strange bishop b5 with
intentions of of course if you go b7 and
i can check you here and take there and
i'm getting the rest of the pawns and
you also have a bishop c4 check these
are all moves you can make but none of
these moves is what stockfish new did in
fact stockpile said i'm going to bring
another piece into the game and leave
all of this right here so if i can rook
lift that's going to be the end of your
shift it's going to be a wrap here if
i'm able to rip lift so after rook a to
d1 there was rook a8 right after rick a8
queen c7 check let me let me go back
here right maybe went too fast there
queen
c7j okay one more time one more time
queen c7 check
how many pieces did we sack here raise
your hand come on right let's let's
retract our memory here how many pieces
did we sacrifice to get here
knight on g5
knight on c6
and now the bishop on a6
if i'm if if the math is correct here
that's a third piece
sacrificed
there's very rare cases that you can
ever sacrifice three pieces and still
win the game
right king takes a6
we don't know what's going to happen
here looks like black's getting mated
somehow queen takes c6 king a7 is
actually plus seven here by the way king
a7 and rook to d3 very strong move
bringing another piece into the game
unbelievable king b8 i'm on i'm on the
run this is a huge king hunt here
and you would like to play rugby three
check right raise your hand rick b three
check oh man we got it and then it's
just 100
garbage not a move bishop takes b3 start
a new game that's over so
you have sacked three pieces
okay
feels like everything's over you don't
have any immediate checks you don't you
don't have anything right what do you do
here i mean this is mind-blowing white
to move let me give you a few seconds
here to figure this one out what do you
do what do you do here
you can't check i mean maybe you have
queen b5 check so you're just gonna go
back and forth perpetual oh man i don't
have enough material anymore i don't
know what to do right i don't know what
to do
what happens what happens in fact here's
the move and actually queen b5 check
runs into king c7 and if you're thinking
you're getting away with something
you're actually not and i'm running and
now i'm up
two not two three pieces on you
that just doesn't work but going back
here
um after oh yeah there's the move right
there brick at five and we live
rook f5
and we live what a move guys what a move
moment of silence
moment of silence
just look at that for a minute like
literally just look at this move for a
second
look at that move i mean rick five is
beautiful rigby five is check and if you
take it it was a diversion
now i have rugby three
and another p sack by the way
this is beautiful i've never seen
anything like it maybe maybe something
like it but this is brilliant obviously
rick f5 very nice move here after rick
f5 it was brooke 287 to try to block
with anything trying to get out of this
thing
rook b5 happens
knight to b6
we take on b6 thanks got one of the
pieces back but we still down material
rook b7 what do you do here what would
you do we doing all of this we're still
down we're still down
some material
still down
two pieces right now
you take on b7 they take back now we get
another piece back thank you very much
queen c7 thanks for the gumdrops and
actually here the knight and the rook
have not moved the entire game
so now those two pieces that you were up
now you're up one piece and you can't
move anything and your king is in the
middle of the street
wow
queen takes e6 97 i gotta develop rigby
three-track king a7 stepping out of the
way miraculously black has not mated
just yet rick a3 check king ba
queen a6 threatening queen aaa mate so
queen c6 says please
please just trade him off okay look hey
i understand great job
great job trade the queens off and then
not today queen a7 check and thank you
for all of my material back
just like
that unbelievable
nasty king
p sac nasty everything sacrifice there i
mean it makes you really want to play
the king's indian or king's gambit i
mean king's gambit again right you want
to literally like pick up some king's
gambit material start playing it today
after this this game queen takes e7 rook
to e8 and here's another shot just shot
after shot not slowing down sacrifice in
pieces i mean who is this stock fish new
rook a8 and we great take those right
and this is beautiful because it's
forced obviously you have to take it and
then we trade into an end game that is 1
000 and percent
winning on every level thank thank you
and the rest is history now watch the
troll moment here from stalker's new we
go get a queen we go get a queen check
right c4 okay makes sense
check king out out of the way and then
g3 pushing and then look at this
check okay
queen a7 is pretty cool and then in fact
the troll moment here was really just
kind of the pawn moves it was kind of
strange after here it was cool to just
see g7 and then c4 and then move the
king over okay
b3 right
b3 guys
b3 what a troll moment and you know it's
like the top engine move too which is so
funny b3 i think uh king to 2d6 f4 check
and then this is the fastest may engines
find it so fast fast as mate here can
you find it maiden two made in two moves
you can pause the video here of course
if you like just to try to find what the
maiden two is there's mate everywhere
made in two making ten making five maybe
twenty two doesn't matter may everywhere
but the fastest mate is actually here on
queen a7 forcing the king to go to b5
the only move don't stalemate that would
be a fatal error and after king 2b5
queen a4 check and nate that was great
that was a beautiful game from stockfish
new planks uh leela chess zero here in
the kings gambit something you usually
don't even see very exciting chess i
hope you guys enjoyed it but uh i'm
national master james canty the third
here with chess.com and i'll see you
guys on the next video
[Music]
you